انتعشت العملات الأجنبية بعد الركود الكبير
في عام 2020، ولكن مع انتعاشها
بقوة شديدة والزيادة في
أسعار الطاقة، كانت أسعار النفط بمثابة
مكاسب غير متوقعة للمملكة العربية السعودية، لذا فقد
حققت نموًا جيدًا للغاية خلال
العام الماضي بلغ حوالي 8.7 في المائة
نموًا قويًا للغاية  تتمتع بوضع مالي قوي للغاية ولديها
الكثير من الإيرادات، لذا فهي في
وضع فريد مقارنة بالعديد من
البلدان الأخرى في العالم. ونحن نعمل بشكل
وثيق جدًا مع المملكة العربية السعودية
لأسباب متعددة بما في ذلك حقيقة أنها
شريك مهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا في
المنطقة.  هناك العديد من البلدان التي
تعاني من مشاكل والمملكة العربية السعودية هي
مزود مهم للتمويل
لهذه البلدان، وهم يعملون بشكل
وثيق مع صندوق النقد الدولي للتأكد من
أن هذا التمويل يساعد على تحفيز الإصلاح
والنمو في هذه الاقتصادات لذلك أعتقد
في هذا البعد أن  تلعب
المملكة العربية السعودية دورًا مهمًا للغاية بالطبع،
تلعب المملكة العربية السعودية دورًا مهمًا للغاية في
أسواق الطاقة التي ستكون
قطاعًا مهمًا للاقتصاد العالمي لفترة طويلة